mike tobin is in la vie of ukraine with
the latest there mike
well a lot of this information is coming
through reporting from the times of
london particularly related to two of
the assassination attempts and this
involves mercenaries with this shadowy
group called the wagner group and
essentially uh they're subcontractors
who would have been working for the the
russian government providing the
russians with some deniability and some
padding there but they according to the
story were pre-placed in kiev and
activated but there were russians who
don't support the war so they leaked
information to the ukrainian security
services and these two assassination
plots were thwarted the other involved
the
chechen hit squad that were part of this
uh cadiros brigades and the khadiro's
brigades are the elite unit named after
ramzan khadirov and they were inserted
into the country when the fighting was
so bad at the hostimo airport there they
came in during the chaos but once again
there were russian turncoats who tipped
off the ukrainians apparently with very
detailed information and the ukrainians
were able to locate the assassins and
kill them right there at the airport uh
that information came through the uh
national security chief
out here in ukraine so real spy stuff
going on out here real cloak and dagger
stuff uh playing out in real life so
mike we're obviously seeing that play
out in ukraine but in russia now we're
seeing vladimir putin shut down facebook
a number of other social media companies
and there's this fear now of him
invoking martial law so we're actually
seeing a number of russians try to leave
the country so can you comment a little
bit about the propaganda war on that end
as well
well as they say the first casualty in
war is the truth there certainly is a
lot of uh propaganda out here and a lot
of bad information that comes out when
you start to see the casualty figures uh
you you can't really trust any of them
you saw the numbers of the casualties uh
that came out from the ukrainians was
dramatically different than what came
out from the from the russians you get a
lot of stories and then you go to find
video of the evidence or find something
that that will support these different
stories that come out and it's just not
there so uh
when you're in an environment like this
you have to double check everything and
uh and uh hope that you don't get
bamboozled in the process
tell us a little bit about this wagner
group i had no idea you could
subcontract out a hit
internationally and then wipe your hands
clean and act like you had plausible
deniability did the did putin actually
think he could pull the trigger on
something like this and no one would
think he was behind it
well a lot of it goes back to that um
that gentleman known as the baker in uh
in uh
in in russian circles and he was uh
tight with putin uh primary or the chef
i should say and he was tight with putin
because putin liked the way he got he
cooked and he got folded into the the
inner circles there so he does a lot of
odd jobs and he is tied with right down
to that internet research association uh
and he is tied into that wagner group of
course can't provide you too much
information because their shadowy
organization their whole uh
their whole backbone of their
organization is their secrecy that's
fascinating thank you do you have a
question for michael yeah actually i do
mike you know we're talking about these
assassination attempts on uh zielinski
have you heard anything about
assassination attempts on putin i mean
even putin's own people are leaking
information to the ukrainians and you
know now they're getting their social
media shut down they've got this
statewide propaganda going on about you
know how they're demilitarizing and
denotifying ukraine do you hear anything
about that
well i can tell you it's very apparent
that putin is paranoid if you look at
the way he sits in all of the meetings
he have even with some of his closest
advisors uh you could you could uh have
a bowling match uh set up between him
and his closest advisors he has to shout
down the table and that's because he
he's fearful of of covid uh they know
that if they get swab that means that
someone could get their dna and custom
design a poison that could just kill him
so uh there's a great deal of paranoia
on putin's part but assassination plots
i imagine they keep that secret
uh yeah i imagine they do
mike um i i would tell people at home to
look up you have guinea progression
because he's the chef that you talked
about and he has been very tight with
putin for a really long time um and he
is believed to be overseeing some of
these operations to kill um to kill
zolensky and you know there were 42
plots
they think probably more than that to
try to kill hitler during world war ii
and none of them succeeded until he
killed himself in a bunker uh in berlin
so
zolensky is obviously under so much
daily pressure what can you tell us
about how he's sort of changing the way
that he navigates and i also read that
that one of the ways they could do it is
to drop like a laser pin on him to try
to figure out you know to try to stick
something on him physically so that they
can find him
well that uh
that's uh that's that's really advanced
i don't have a whole lot about that but
as far as um the pressure that zielenski
is under and what he's doing you keep in
mind uh while you have the the the
russian leaders are paranoid and they
won't sit next to their closest advisors
zielinski is doing press conferences and
he is in the middle of all of this and
one thing that has happened out here
particularly in the west he wasn't that
popular and he wasn't that respected uh
this is a guy who was an actor who
uh fell into this job
and even his political party is named
after the political party from the tv
series he was in a lot of people just
thought that he wasn't up to the task
and he has risen to the occasion not
only so the people who didn't like him
in the western part of the country are
now backing him if you saw some of these
scenes of of of this broadcast address
he just did the wencesla square there
and the czech republic is just packed
with people who are now rallying behind
zelensky so it's uh it's it's remarkable
the extent to which this guy has risen
to the occasion craig yeah like um so
i've read and i
i should have uh double checked this but
i i had read
that russia passed a new law imposing
prison terms for spreading
misinformation about the russian
military uh and the the depressing part
about this is that there were no
lawmakers or in the or in their
parliamentary chambers that oppose the
bill
and if i i'm coming from the point of
view that the key here is you have to
persuade powerful russians not just the
population but powerful russians that
putin is just not destroying ukraine but
destroying russia and they have to save
it but when you see lawmakers in these
chambers
not opposing this bill that's kind of
depressing though
sure and then now that it goes through
when you start to talk about
misinformation in the press well the
definition of fake news as is popular
and popularly interpreted is anything
you don't want to hear right so if a
reporter puts out something the
government doesn't like it's
you could be looking at prison time and
therefore you're going to have a
controlled media and i've been in these
countries where the media is controlled
and usually the front page of the
newspaper is just ridiculous it's
praising whoever is in power at the time
and then what you get is no mistrust
with the people because they know what
they're looking at the front page in the
newspaper is just entirely controlled
all right mike tobin thank you so much
stay safe